so there were a lot of favorite
candidates to win the succession war
like you've got first Prince Benjamin
and his personal army Camilla and her
unkillable nature and there's even Zhang
Li who has some well he has coins I
guess however my favorite candidate by
far would be 4th Prince subscribe nick
who has the ability to allow you to
subscribe to the new order view for
regular hunt hunter content uploaded
straight into your YouTube feed go forth
print subscribe Nick
hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today it's time for some
glorious glorious speculation regarding
the future events of Honda hunters
succession walk which I know I talked
about a great length but I just love it
an insane amount for an arc that is no
when you complete and now I know there's
also a huge sect of those out there that
may find this video pointless as they
have given up all hope of Hunter hunter
ever returning that is not how we
operate here so today let us have a
potential glimpse into the future and so
I have a series of what I'm going to
call moderately thought-out predictions
here but first up I want to state that I
won't really be going over material that
I have covered extensively in other
videos for example probably my most
major succession war prediction is that
I believe that crop oka will be dead by
at the end of the arc but we have a
whole video discussing that one idea
link in the description below if you're
interested but let's move on to some new
material and that's for my first
potentially foolish prediction I am
going to put it out there that I believe
multiple princes will survive the war so
generally when I engage in discussion
surrounding the princes I am kind of
forced to use the framing that the
series has given us which is that in
theory only one of them will be alive at
the conclusion of this arc but at the
same time hunter hunter has almost never
followed the narrative setup at the
beginning of an arc so I don't see why
it would need to do so here and I guess
the main thing to remember regarding
this war is that this is probably unlike
every other previous contest that the
[ __ ] in Empire has engaged in because we
have a plethora of chaotic figures board
like crop pick ax the zodiacs and the
Phantom Troop all of whom are currently
capable of overpowering most of the
princes in regards to nen and all of
whom are profound individuals within the
series in their own right so this
contest is not going to be an isolated
affair and so I find it very unlikely
that everything would go you know
according to keikaku which may result in
something of an anticlimactic outcome
with a handful of Prince's remaining in
this world and the conditions of the
contest defeated or worked around
because no form of nen is invincible in
addition to this despite the rankings I
gave in my who will win the succession
war video
Takashi is the kind of guy
would abandon all reasonable thought in
regards to a clear front-runner and we
could very much end up in a position
where someone like Zhang lay the
middling candidate not a favorite but
certainly someone to be taken seriously
achieves the form of victory by default
by being the oldest remaining Prince
after the conditions of the contest of
being dispelled and that would make even
more sense if the group he was left with
consisted of figures like 'whoa bull and
Miriam you know children who don't have
the capacity to rule as of yet in any
case just judging by Takashi's habit of
not finishing what he sets up they feel
like betting a multiple prints of
surviving this conflict is a pretty
alright idea although it might be thrown
into complete chaos by my next thought
which is that by the end of the
succession walk I believe that the
Blackwell one will be completely
destroyed and we're seeing the
beginnings of this right now in terms of
the Mafia power struggles happening on
the lower decks mainly caused by a
certain marina the leader of the Haley
family whose primary mission in life is
to spread anarchy and destroy this world
which she finds so profoundly disgusting
and turn an ability contagion which
we've spoken about a couple of times
already allows her to do just that by
infecting others and spreading the
practice of incentivized murder as if it
were a disease and at the time of this
recording hundreds of people have
already died simply as a result of the
Haley family's actions which might sound
like a slow start with 200,000 people
aboard the black whale one but this is
going to get very out of hand very very
quickly as viruses often do potentially
leading to mass chaos would no escape
and thus contributing to the result of
the black whale vessel and this is a
situation that means Iceland has
anticipated and even foreshadowed which
given my logic surrounding the last
prediction you would think that I'd go
against a clearly set up plot point but
in this case I think that the integrity
of the black whale one is going to be a
near impossible thing to secure because
in addition to the Mafia families we
also have the Phantom troupe as well as
the potential for the succession wall on
tier one to spill on to the lower decks
which might be according to the master
plan of sacrifice for the cocoon Empire
but a lot of my thinking here also has
to do with looking forward because at
the moment the plan is to dump the
cocaine Empire on the new continent and
pretend it's the Dark Continent then
taking the true expedition team on a
ship captained by Morel however if the
cocoon Empire still has access to a
black whale one then there would be no
stopping them from moving on as well
because at some point they will surely
discover the deception of the hunter
Association and the v5 nations but
without a vessel capable of sailing
through the exceptionally dangerous
waters that they would have no other
option but to stay on the new continent
now when we're
guards to how they would get there at
all the Blackwell one has always
intrigued me because it appears to have
a ship sitting right on top of it so I
would say that's a very convenient
method of escape for those who do
survive the ensuing chaos in order to
make it to the new continent that or the
survivors are picked up by moral
separate ship but either way I suspect
that this bulky unit is most certainly
going down and as for who said survivors
are going to be this touches on yet
another prediction I have which is that
the Phantom troop will all die no
exceptions these guys have been a force
to be reckoned with for most of the
lifespan of the series but I get the
distinct feeling that their story along
with several others are destined to come
to an end during the succession wall and
now I won't lie part of this is because
I really don't know how realistic it is
for Hunter hunter to continue beyond
this arm and having them all here
alongside Hisoka and Cora pika very much
ties all of their story threads in the
series together setting the stage for
their sudden but inevitable deaths just
like their former compatriots Sherlock
and corto be the only way I could see
any of the troops surviving is if he
Sokka had a grander purpose in the story
going forward which I did explore in
great length in another video but I find
it far more likely and much neater that
they will all meet their demise right
here and now removed from any possible
form of escape next up let's move back
to the princess for a bit and
specifically to focus on baby Prince
bobble the only one whose nan based
currently remains unknown now I know the
fun joke to spread about this is that
Korra pica is vocals nan based which
honestly I would take over any of the
others we've seen but this prince did a
DTEC pot in the sea tone ceremony and so
we are still waiting for her true beast
to manifest and when it does I suspect
that it will be the key to everything
now that is a very vague statement and I
made it purposely vague because
originally what I wanted to predict was
that warbles nan beasts would be the
most powerful of all the princes in an
attempt for the succession want to
balance out its contestants by giving
the lesser skilled princes the more
potent power in retrospect though that
doesn't really seem to be the case and
all of the beasts thus far seem to be
about equal if not skewed in favor of
the older princes however warbles
unknown in base provides a nice get out
of jail free card for Takashi in any
given situation like for example if we
got to a point where croco was facing
off against rhinock and is in a position
of losing then warbles NIMBYs could
interrupt with some obscure ability for
karateka to take advantage of and
ultimately defeats a ride Nick and I
guess that's what I mean by the vague
key to everything statement his beasts
probably won't be the most powerful but
it will have some sort of strange
utility that only some
with the brilliant mind of crop oka
would be able to use and ensure its uses
safety and my next prediction is also
prints related quite specifically to 9th
Prince Hulkenberg who has been
consistently portrayed as one of the
more noble existences amongst the [ __ ]
in royalty blatantly opposing the
politics of the nation and wishing for
radical change
furthermore he's also a pacifist Argus
was because he has since abandoned that
way of life for the greater goal of
winning the contest so I proposed to you
that by the end of this arc Hulkenberg
will be completely corrupted he's
already taken the first step in
abandoning his previously established
ways of life so I think that what we
have on our hands here is a classic road
to hell paved with good intentions kind
of deal and it's not just him who would
be subject to that but all of his
followers as well who are supremely
loyal to Hawke and Burke in fact loyalty
is a huge condition for the ability of
his nan beast so we could see the
development of a very suddenly extreme
faction which would you know see
hülkenberg live so long that he becomes
a villain in the same way that we would
currently see so radnik Camilla and
Benjamin and it's going to be ever so
heartbreaking because togarashi has put
a lot of emotional weight on this Prince
so it's not something I look forward to
seeing but I can't deny the strong
possibility and for this video I also
have one final prediction which takes us
back to the Phantom troop and it's
certainly not an original idea in fact
this has been floated around the
internet for quite some time now but I
think that this is the first time I've
addressed it on this channel and that is
the thought that illah me is actually
Hisoka now this might sound pretty
full-on insane at first but it's an idea
that I find myself more and more drawn
to because I think it is technically
possible because after being revived
from death Hisoka stabilities became
significantly more powerful and if
togarashi wanted to do this then I don't
see why he soccer could not use texture
surprise on his entire body and just
imitate alumi they're both quite tall
slender figures in fact there's only a
two centimeter height difference between
them with Hisoka being the taller figure
standing at 187 centimeters by the way
but this sort of shenanigan reach is
exactly the kind of business that the
mad magician would pull I mean he has
infiltrated the troupe once before with
the purpose of fighting crawler so why
not again and it would also explain why
nobody can find him plus there is also
reason to be skeptical of illumise
entire motivation here because last we
saw this man he was pretty hell-bent on
continuing his quest to control kill OA
in order to control a locker by proxy
and now he's taken in complete 180 and
accepted a commission to kill Hisoka I
mean yes he's a professional assassin at
heart and he and he so could do have
this way
kind of killi killi bond going on so
it's not the most outrageous idea in the
world to just take what's happening at
face value but I am personally not going
to believe anything until I see ill amis
abilities used aboard the black whale
one although the other thing that
dispels this idea is that you'd think
Kyoto might probably know if this wasn't
the real enemy so maybe this is just me
hoping for some giant Hisoka flavor
twist and not accepting that sometimes
this series is just incredibly
straightforward which to be fair on the
odd occasion it is but that pretty much
does it for this set of predictions for
the succession will arc if you enjoyed
this video on the content this channel
produced in general then please do
consider donating to the new worldview
patreon because the support of all of
your amazing people is what continues to
make this channel possible and if
patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video like share or
subscribe because it also helps for this
channel an incredible amount and if
you'd like to join the fun at any time
then please do head over to my disco
server where a wide array of Shannara
takes place on a daily basis and finally
please do comment with your own
succession wall predictions this has
been the new world review and I'll see
you next time
if you could choose the next Prime
Minister between Paris 10 he'll
representing the Tories tompa
representing labor well he so could
representing what I'm assuming is the
Liberal Democrats who would you pick so
this question sucks because no matter
what happens we end up in a distinct
dystopia so first of all I'm not very
well versed in UK politics being on the
other side of the world and all so the
specific parties themselves mean very
little to me which is probably for the
best because nobody wants politics
involved in fun anime videos anyway but
in regards to the candidates themselves
if your choice is a corrupt masterminded
Harriston he'll an incompetent fool in
Tompa or a mass-murdering magician who
would probably implement a policy to
turn the entire world into a purge movie
style type system whereby a couple of
nights a year or indeed all night SIA
you were just free to kill without
repercussions and I'd say oh this is
tough
let's go with Tompa because I guess he's
incompetent which means that at the very
least even if he was corrupt he might
accidentally do something right or just
completely failed to implement any of
his corruption which is far more than we
could hope for from parastone or Hisoka